l'olympia la cigale ou encore l'européen
autant de salles de spectacles qui
accueille depuis quelques jours le
festival de musique intitulé les jeux un
festival dans la fiche regroupe
quelques-uns des nouveaux talents de la
scène française pop ou rock
parmi eux quelques noms qui ont déjà
largement fait leurs preuves comme m
matthieu chedid qui vient d'être
consacré aux victoires de la musique ou
encore catherine qui passe demain soir à
la cigale marie bérurier emmanuel
hunzinger le rencontrer
le bonne heure
c'est qu'on prend
non sa vie n'est pas devenu un clic non
il n'a pas encore la grosse tête
oui il s'appelle toujours catherine et
là il retrouve enfin son groupe fétiche
mais recycleurs toujours des musiciens
vous passionne pas voilà qui viennent du
jazz plutôt et de musique à la fois
électronique et d'improvisation et avec
qui à faire de la musique facile quoi et
ça va vite il ya toujours plein de
solutions s'ils sont très inventive
ouzou d'aubais dont jean moulin
selon le monde
mon choix la dernière fois c'était à
l'automne
on l'avait laissé avec un double album
les créatures et l'homme à trois mains
de céder étranges et plutôt réussi
depuis il se montre pas mal squattent
les hôtels et écrit des chansons pour un
à karina je vis de la musique depuis
cinq ou six ans en faisant des concerts
vous sera les 10 donc pour moi c'est ça
c'est ça l'important
et puis comme on me reconnais pas
particulièrement dans la rue c'est
absolument pas un succès populaire donc
comme c'est même pas non plus ce que je
veux je me sens assez bien cette chanson
voilà et pour le voir ou le revoir un
seul rendez vous c'est demain soir à la
cigale
moi je suis un poète
nan mais